joining us now to discuss the global
health crisis in detail is CBS news
medical contributor dr. David agus dr.
good morning morning Jeff so a lot we
don't know about corona right what are
the symptoms and how easily can it
spread as far as what we know right now
so there different types of corona virus
the common cold about a third of them
are a type of corona virus but this is
an aggressive type of corona virus that
classically goes to the lung and causes
an immune response as that immune
response gets greater it's harder and
harder to breathe and that's what we're
seeing in patients is that they're
admitted to a hospital and then slowly
it gets worse so they can't breathe and
that's why they passed away from this
horrible virus and the most vulnerable
being the young and the elderly on the
other although we're seeing 2030 and
four-year-olds die I mean there's an
amazing case just reported if somebody
admitted to a hospital china with
abdominal pain and 12 healthcare workers
died because they were exposed not
knowing that corona virus so the cdc now
has estimated that there have been
12,000 deaths from the flu just the flu
how how worried should Americans be
about corona virus corona virus is not
going to cause a major is the united
states if we have it here we're very we
have healthcare institutions that can
cordon people off we could take care of
them give what we call supportive care
remember this happened in a part of
China where there wasn't great medical
systems which is why they had to build
these thousand bed hospitals in a matter
of a week so in the United States won't
be an issue but it just begs you and
pushes you why then why isn't everybody
getting a flu vaccine we're gonna have
forty to sixty thousand deaths this year
in the United States from the influenza
and it's preventable and there are only
12 confirmed cases of coronavirus here
in the states no question about it those
are enormous difference in numbers and
we have to step up as a nation and start
to prevent along the lines of those who
do have it though and this idea you and
I were talking before the show is there
a vaccination is there something that's
working in order to finally contain and
stop this at some point so we have
treatments that we think work they work
for similar viruses and there's some
data now they worked in Asia in certain
patients and those are generic drugs
that are available that were originally
meant to treat HIV or influenza they
work against this type of corona virus
the clinical trial validating this is
ongoing in China but my gut is there
will be some benefit there and we have
the
drugs supportive care we have and
vaccines are being developed it's gonna
be at least a year and a half till we
have a real vaccine but there's hope
here that we have these drugs that work
come on go ahead go ahead doesn't say
along the lines though then in trying to
stop the spread we see people wearing
masks is that enough
ah so these mess you know it's called
n95 which means it prevents 95% of thing
going in what it doesn't prevent is
really small things viruses are really
really small so they will not prevent
viruses from getting in but and will
prevent droplets so there's a droplet in
the air that mask can catch it so it's
not wrong to wear a mask but they don't
do that much to spread stop the spread
of virus oh they kind of look kind of
cool with how much worse does this get
in China before it gets better that's
that's the million-dollar question is
that there's the epidemiology are saying
it probably will peak over the next week
and then go down into murder cases and
then a second peak in the fall toward
the end of the year as classically
happened without breaks like this the
true answer is we don't know there's not
a lot of transparency in China they
don't have enough tests they're only
testing the people who are really really
ill the people were mild to moderate
aren't even being tested so when you're
not told you're positive you'd go out
you could spread to somebody else this
is a public health nightmare which is
why it seems so crazy that people are
being kept in their homes but it's the
only way to stop that spread for certain
dr. David agus thank you